President Trump tweeted yesterday that
Attorney General Jeff Sessions should
end the special counsels Russia
investigation he's called it again a
rigged witch-hunt is that obstruction of
justice well I don't know what the legal
definition of that would be regards to
tweets I don't think that's ever been
litigated here's the bottom line I'm not
gonna spend my time here in the US
Senate waking up every morning and
responding to some tweet every day
okay I know you know that's what you
guys are paid to do and that's fine if
it's something that directive on public
policy but I'm gonna spend my time in
the US Senate working on paid family
leave I'm gonna spend my time in the US
Senate fighting against you know the
efforts of the Chinese to overtake us
and they to a political stage I'm gonna
spend my time fighting for the people of
Florida and on issues that are important
and when something big comes up that
needs to be addressed well address it my
feet my views of the Moller
investigation are clear I think that he
should be allowed to finish his work
that all the truth come out and that the
truth is going to be good for the
president and good for America and that
remains my view and the president has a
different view that certainly that's his
right and and and you guys can ask him
about it you can ask the White House
about it all of our